you look at the davos types the global
elite let's say
they've really got three main objectives
and and i could go into great great
detail on this but uh their first
objective is to reduce the energy
consumption at a global level
their second cause they're all
malthusians their second objective
explain what mouth is you need to break
that one down okay so thomas malthus was
an individual that lived in the 1800s
and he was the first person to
articulate this view that if you have
exponential population growth in a world
of limited resources you're going to run
into some big problems the only release
valve there will be the standard of
living so you need to proactively try to
reduce energy consumption and you need
to proactively reduce the birth rate
as your duty as a good proactively how
though through war through famine
well so he had two
kind of levers there yeah he said let's
embrace war let's embrace famine because
it brings down the population to where
it's at equilibrium with our resources
which is
effed up you know obviously
and then he said
and then let's also try to limit the
number of kids we have instead of having
three or four let's just have one or two
and and china yeah
and you know
one kid for however many decades they
used to be the one child policy is gone
now but yeah clearly because they're
just does a very malthusian type type of
view which and also you know they're the
club of rome is what really kind of got
these ideas going again in the 1970s
with a paper called limits to growth
that came out in 1972
and the person that wrote that paper was
actually the keynote uh presenter at
davos at the world economic forum by
klaus schwab what year was that 1973.
the first as the first year was 71 71
was the first year 72 the limits to
growth came out in 73 the gentleman was
the keynote speaker at klaus's event so
and then the third thing is they just
want to use cert power control and
wealth because they figure that's the
way that they're going to achieve those
first two objectives and anything else
that they want to do
so
i think when you look at things through
that lens you know you ask yourself why
is the davos type always
pro
woke agenda let's say right
why is it that they're always in favor
of disney saying that 50 of their
characters are going to be lgbtq
whatever it is now right
um it's it's i'm not saying that they're
behind that but they're
really cheerleading it because it helps
them achieve that second objective you
know they don't care it's a second
objective reduce the birth rate they
don't care about women uh being
empowered you know they just say they
want that because that's going to reduce
the birth rate i'm not saying that uh
women being empowered or 60 of the
university students being women is a bad
thing i'll let that you know you be the
judge but what i'm saying is that
there's a cost benefit that needs to be
done and you have to realize that if
there's a benefit fine but the cost is
going to be lowering the birth rate if
we lower the birth rate that's going to
create macro economic problems in the
future let's go complete like different
angle right now not different angle but
um
good bad and ugly basically give me like
if you're a member of the globalist
elite davos
give me like the reason that it's a
necessity to have this meeting and what
all the benefits are give me that and
then give me the counterpoint of like
give me the most
evil you know
darkest secret of what they're talking
about you know what i'm talking about
like
liberals eating babies give me just the
most positive and the most negative from
this world economic forum in doubles i
don't know what the positive and
negative the extreme yeah but i've done
a lot of research on this i just did a
presentation at a live event a couple
weeks on it a couple weeks ago on it and
i think that uh
it all
goes back to one chart and if you look
at a chart of energy use since 1800s it
explains everything
so what happened in 1800 about 99 of our
energy came from a biofuels so basically
dried cow dung and lumber
and then we got coal and then we had oil
and we have natural gas and then we have
renewables and we have new fracking we
have all these things right so what you
see starting about the 1950s is the
amount of energy we use goes exponential
now the popul the global population
follows the exact same curve as does
global gdp growth
so you have to come to the conclusion
that that energy is the economy and
energy is what allows the population to
continue to flourish all right well if
you're looking at this through that
malthusian lens you're saying okay at
some time uh in the near future this
resource or these resources that we have
access that's got a flat line
so that means that if the population
continues to grow exponentially the
standard of living has to go down
so we need to take it upon ourselves to
pull those first two levers to make sure
that we buy enough time for renewables
to not only replace see that's a
complete misnomer renewables can't just
replace the existing fossil fuels they
have to add to it because let's go back
to biofuels every single time that we
get a new energy source that's superior
we don't stop using
the last energy source we had
we in fact often use more of it so today
we're using more biofuels than we did in
1800
we're using more coal we're using more
oil and so it those energy sources just
grow and again that's what allows the
population to grow so the global elite
look at this and say okay well
we've got to kick the can further down
the road to allow renewables not only
replace but add to the level of energy
we have access to right now so we need
to manipulate the paul the global
population to use we need to condition
them to use less energy and then also if
we can lower the birth rate then we're
going to have more energy per capita and
we can buy more time
and then i think the fringe benefit
there is that
if we get into a situation where they're
just not able to create enough energy by
conditioning the public to use less it
allows them to use more so as my good
friend chris martinson always says they
want you to take a cold shower so they
can continue to fly around the world in
their private jet
you know something like this and so not
only do they have this malthusian view
but they have a uh
it's it's in my opinion it's borderline
uh
eugenics yeah where uh you know
eugenicist believes that there's a group
of people that are just superior right
and the rest of those people are just
inferior so if we could just weed out
those people that are inferior that
would be better for society long term
so if you think about your typical
central planner right marxist let's say
a socialist
they they don't they might not go that
extreme but it's a very similar view
that there's a group of people that
should be calling the shots for everyone
else because that group of people is
just better at making decisions
so
you know what i would suggest
looking at that problem of that
exponential growth curve and energy or a
malthusian view is i'd say listen we
need more free market capitalism
because if we have an extra 2 billion
people on earth great that's an extra 2
billion people that can solve these
problems that are real but they can't
handle that because in their world view
they're the smartest
people on the planet so if they can't
fix the problem well you dumb rubes out
there in society can't fix it either so
to make sure that we've got the best
chance of fixing this we need to use the
power we need the control we need the
wealth and it's just for the greater
good so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauscast click
right here
[Music]